[smooth jazz music]
Welcome back
to The Morty Jebsen Show.
I'm Morty Jebsen.
We're here today
continuing our conversation
with unbelievable
mega superstar
Young Bidness.
Now, Young Bidness,
I got to tell you,
we've been
tiptoeing around
a particular subject
all day,
and I think it's time
to broach it.
You've separated recently
with your actress girlfriend,
Tina Bouquet.
- No, Mort, Mort.
- And everybody wants to know--
We ain't gonna talk
about that.
I'm not here
to talk about that.
I just want to hear
your side of the story.
You don't want to hear--
I told y'all motherfuckers
we weren't gonna talk
about that, Mort.
I'm trying to talk
about the music.
And lots of people understand
that you're talking
about your own
personal experiences.
Your fans
would like to know--
How many times
I need--
Why--what--
The fans don't want to know.
That's--
You want to know!
- I just want to clarify--
- You want to know.
You ain't want to clari--
You want clarification?
I want to hear your side
of the story.
I'll tell you
my side of the story.
Interview's over.
How about that?
- Please, Young Bidness.
- Done.
There's no need
for the interview to be over.
Interview's over.
All y'all
motherfuckers.
Young Bidness, there's no need
for the language or any of this.
All y'all--
I told y'all motherfuckers
I wasn't gonna talk
about that.
Do you want to talk
about the album?
'Cause I'd be more than happy
to talk about the album.
- This is the C-Word.
- Mort.
It looks like it's well
on its way to going platinum.
Fuck--Get the fuck
away from me, nigga.
Louis, Louis.
Well on its way
to going platinum.
We can talk
about this.
This shit
is tucked in here.
It's fine with me.
You want to talk
about the album?
We can talk
about the album.
How about Tanks of Truth?
Tanks of Truth--
is that a treatise
on the conflict
with ISIS?
I mean, what--
talk to me about this.
What--
Young Bidness, please,
I'm begging you.
Just sit down,
take a deep breath,
and let's discuss.
- No.
- Let's discuss the album.
It's done, Mort.
It's done.
So...
You brought this
on yourself, Mort.
- Young Bidness--
- You brought it on yourself.
Young Bidness,
I would really love it
if you had a seat,
and we could just
talk together
about anything--
anything you want.
We don't--I won't mention
Tina's name again.
Young Bidness.
How the fuck--
Youthful--
How does--
where does it go to?
Louis, help him.
No, get the fuck--
get the fuck off me, Louis.
Louis, go.
Leave it be.
You're exacerbating
the situation.
(Young Bidness)
This shit
attached to?
- It's probably--
- It's just a lot of slack.
The cord is blending in
with the color of the carpet.
- So what--what--
- Okay, I just think that--
Young Bidness, why don't
you drop the mic cable
and have a seat?
This is what we used to call
back in the Army a FUBAR.
Let me just--okay,
let me just tell you--
No, get--
don't get involved.
We have to get you
out of here.
Amy, please,
can we just get--
Listen--
Here, If you let go of it...
Let me get in there.
Don't get in it.
Don't--See?
I'm trying
to get around--
Don't step
on my jacket!
$1,500 jacket, bitch.
Get--
Why do we have black cords
and a black carpet?
All right, well,
you motherfuckers--
I told y'all I wasn't gonna--
Louis, I swear to fucking God!
We're gonna
take care of it.
Just stay put.
Now you got--
Now I seemed to have gotten
myself tangled in it.
Don't--you ain't--
Get off me, man.
Now it's just me.
Can I--may I help you?
Don't touch the jacket.
I'm sorry.
Look, okay, here's--
- Raise you knee.
- There's one end right here.
- You got to get--Now--
- Hold on. I got bursitis.
You know what?
Here.
Here's what
we're gonna do.
Have a seat here.
Put your fanny right here.
- Don't say "fanny."
- There.
- There you go.
- All right.
How you--You do it--
What, you do this--
Don't.
You ain't taking
the pants off.
Nicole, God damn it.
Where is Jerry?
This is some shit
right here.
Same sound guy
for 27 years,
and he vanishes
into thin air.
All right,
all right, no.
Nicole,
for God's sake.
All right,
Louis, Louis.
Hold that.
Don't do anything
but hold that.
Okay, no, no.
You got to put--
No, nigga,
you got to take--
No, you can't take
the pants off over the shoes!
You can't take
Louis, Louis,
get your white ass
out the motherfucker.
You ain't
helping nobody.
- All right, all right.
- I'm taking the shoes off.
Okay, left one first.
All right, well...
do whatever the fuck you want,
then, nigga, fine.
Thank you.
One, two...
Thank you!
I told y'all I wasn't
gonna talk about that shit!
We'll be right back
with Alec Baldwin.